This dish is called Verine or Belliem, which is a type of small
glass.The dishes and sweets served in it are also called by that name.The
visual beauty of layers of sauces and mousses is layered.  Tsuga is poisonous
But his daily
Japanese sake The color is too dark to reach 100 layers It
's a pile of
thunder It's just
an
amuse  Hey, 10 seconds I'm going to finish it within 30 seconds, but what
is it?  Yes
[music]
Mm, lots of fruit - Is it joint with the church?
Mr. Kuninari's mousse, which is sandwiched in a hurry and glitters, will become an accent, and I think one after another.
It looks like it's going to dance in the dark But what does it mean? I felt that great shock, but the
rest is light as if it's a lie
The surgery is probably because of this, the inside
is well There are countless extremely complicated people engraved
Every time I shake  Before this groove gave birth
to Sosai Naha, I also made a pin pad mandoka
ni
[music]